appears to be fired for his views on
gender yep
oh my god well I think the way that
paid specifically non-binary people mock
them you make fun of them you use them
as entertainment use the lives of real
people in this country why did we give
the Geeks platforms
why are they on the news well let's hear
what he has to say before we hate on him
I guess that was hypocritical because
everyone should be able to speak their
mind but like when did these why do we
listen to this [ __ ] so religiously
minority as something to make fun of and
get a reaction and I don't think that's
the quality Journey when has he done
that but that's just it here they're
right here's the problem I don't think
he's done that that I have seen and she
said that when has he done that so just
because somebody is criticizing or
saying that somebody is full of sh
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
using them as a circus clown when
meanwhile you've got transgender people
literally acting like not all by any
stretch the ones that are in the public
eye acting like legit circus clowns and
this guy is upset when then people call
them circumstances look at this NPC news
station England game halted twice over
racist abusive players Pierce Morgan
sacker save over the over what he calls
trans people like this is not news you
guys are idiots
yeah you know why I did that because
human eye had this debate about the
hundred genders I made the point if
literally you can now identify in a
hundred different ways you're gender
including two-spirit persons and all
this other stuff then I'm entitled to
identify as a two-spirit penguin in
other words there are no limits and
what's interesting is you want me to
respect all those hundred genders
however ludicrous some of them are but
you have zero respect for my right to
identify myself in any way I see fear so
in other words it's one rule for you you
say Everyone's entitled to say yes he's
totally right I decide
you go absolutely nuts and want to
control how I self-identify that's not
that's what point I'm making but it's
not transphobic okay but it's exposing a
floor in your position it isn't because
being a penguin isn't a gender that's
not on the gender Spectrum
it doesn't matter how many times you
pretend to be Pingu Morgan that's still
not a gender that people can identify
with who are you what are these other
hundred genders are things that people
can identify with you're making [ __ ] up
they just make things up the Caesars 100
different genders give me a [ __ ]
break I am so tired of this foolishness
there will be people watching this
program this morning 100 different ways
to be mentally ill there are trans that
are not a binary and it can do real
damage when I was growing up I watched
gmtv religiously and I was gay and
unsure about my sexuality and I fear
that if that had been mocked constantly
on breakfast Telly there are a bit of
damage but on that point there are a few
people who have been turn it off turn it
off if you don't feel good when you
watch it
I have relentlessly on this program to
zero credit for people like you right I
don't think they're not making games
nobody has been louder and proud in
promoting trans rights right and India
will confirm that because she's seen it
and she's responded to it and come on
and debated it with me so when you call
me racist homophobic I've seen all the
stuff on Twitter in the last two days
right Mr better apparently I'm racist
I'm transphobic I'm uh bigoted I'm
homophone you can't just be one of them
you have to be if they're gonna come at
you with a one in fullback or ISM
if you don't like what somebody has on
the dinner table you're racist you know
if it happens to be an ethnic dish and
you just don't like the dish for because
you don't like the way it tastes or
smells or looks or you don't like the
ingredients that makes you racist every
they just make everything they make
everything everything is is an IST
everything everybody has a label just
because we disagree you got to be
labeled so exhausting that none of it
matters anymore it is baloney it is
baloney it's all baloney none of it
means anything if you call everybody
racist over everything nobody's racist
let's all just leave it alone did the
word racist used to mean something when
you were growing up it used to be like
actually a real word and now it's just
like legit means nothing it had some it
it it had it had some some kick to it
and now they've overused it so much the
way the feminists have with the metoo
movement and they they turned uh sexual
harassment and assault into you know
what used to be a really terrible thing
and now every little thing that happens
that they don't like a guy in the office
says hi every morning and it makes them
feel uncomfortable that you know another
being sexually harassed and that guy
should be fired it's ridiculous nothing
they've ruined everything they've taken
real issues and everything they've taken
real issues and watered them down and
made them meaningless and for some
people that are really suffering from
assaults or racism or you know some kind
of real real discrimination they're
gonna be they're being ignored because
nobody can listen to this [ __ ]
anymore and it's a shame look at this is
Harry Potter looking [ __ ] what
is going to be happening
it has no logic it's like a geek
completely
he's not feeling sensed about this 100
gender thing imagine being in the India
will have it he's gone through
transitioning which is an extraordinary
difficult emotional psychological and
physical process lasting a long period
of time and then when you finally get to
transition to be a woman right having
wanted to be that your whole life I love
how he's like when you finally get the
transition to be a woman like you don't
be or you don't become a woman no he's
just being nice yeah it's just dumb
though it's meaningless because there
are no 100 ways to identify General
India yeah I I I think peers is a beacon
of light and most trans people and I'm
actually going to use the word
transitioners here because the fact that
wait just stopped for a second says
Pierce should keep his job the fact that
that they're they're debating whether or
not he should be fired over this is the
real disgrace here I don't care what
they're talking about the fact that I
know I know I know it annoys me that
this is probably the most popular TV
show in Britain that hundreds of
millions of people watch and that
they're they're debating that they're
putting this in people's heads that they
that you should be sacked if you're not
if you're not PC if you don't say so if
you don't say something [ __ ] this I
don't even rock with Pierce like that
after the Tate interview he's a straight
agent of the Matrix he very well made
but you said 24 year old woman aren't as
attractive as 20 year old women like oh
are there clouds out today is the sky
blue transgender now is about floating
about in the middle no commitment you
pick and choose who you want to be and
with the greatest respect I don't need
any gay people coming in to represent me
because I'm trans it's not the same as
being gay and if you're saying that you
know this is making a mockery of gender
well what what's your views on drag I
find drag far more offensive than
anything that probably says
no but drag is gay men dressing up as
women in a flamboyant way exaggerated
Manner and mannerisms
it is it is that's a ridiculous comment
do you not accept that so I I you know
becomes so embarrassing because of
people like you and what you challenge
I'm ashamed of it he must be awful there
are people there are bigoted people I
don't accept there are a hundreds
who don't recognize your identity why
does it make why is it okay when you
recognize that that is unacceptable and
bigoted for you to turn to non-binary
people and say you don't recognize their
identity isn't that a race listen how
can non-binary I honestly
I want to see her question her answer
please before transgender what exactly
are you trying the umbrella you don't
even believe in gender so how can you be
transcended it's made a mockery
okay so yeah you know I see his point if
she said that so his point is if you
know how how could you be how could you
not validate them if if you're not
Consolidated right but you know what
maybe she doesn't care like me like I
have all these feminists floating around
telling me that I'm held back because
I'm I'm a woman and I've been held back
my whole life and I'm like I don't give
a [ __ ] nobody's holding me back if
there's a dozen men over there and half
of them are you know cool and half of
them think that I shouldn't be doing
anything of value because I'm a woman I
don't care would that ladder have things
don't give a [ __ ] and I and I don't have
to live my life based on what someone is
in somebody else's mind because our laws
are in place to protect me from
discrimination so it's that's it so this
guy wants you know because there's a
half a dozen people in England who feel
hurt or hate or you know hate hate
transgenders who cares let them hate
them pray for them and carry on with
your life they're not stopping you from
doing anything that's what I was just
gonna say about what I respect about her
is like she's just transgender and
that's it like she just minds her own
business like who cares she's not
complaining no I know that's what I'm
saying yeah
I've been subjected to more foul abuse
on social media Captain I have in the
last few days since his campaign started
against me there is an aspect of I'm
afraid your lobby group for what I'm
about the gender Lobby Group which is
highly abusive he wants everybody that
they don't have to be fired canceled
destroyed and everything else and I say
what is wrong with debate you and I came
on and we debated it on here right yeah
I actually learned a bit from you and
perhaps you learned a bit from me and
maybe you didn't but your response to a
good natured debate on this and I've
come back on and demand I get fired
because we only want people sitting here
that you agree with and I say that most
people most people and I say this with
respect to you most people think the
concept of a hundred genders is utter
nonsense and if it takes me to say on
television get away from this this
ridiculous control freakery stuff that
no one's allowed to challenge it if it's
to me that says that I'm gonna say it
and you're not gonna stop me and you're
not going to get me fired and what
exactly is your ex expertise on gender
have you got any gender issues I'm a
cisgendered male and I'm feeling so
you're happy to be comfortable in that
then you'll have to explain yourself
wait that's an actual dude or is this a
trend this isn't a trend no no he's just
a gay dude I thought he was a trainer
and I identity I was born as a man and I
identity but between man you don't need
cysts when you think you're under attack
imagine being someone who has been
criticized by their friends by their
family by their school by parts of the
media from the day though
everybody has I love that I love that
imagine being somebody who's been
criticized by your friends about your
family by the media he's a white man I
felt right right by just for who you are
as any person that's what happens I
don't know anybody live in a family that
is is the goddamn Waltons because I
don't know but there's a lot of
criticism and every person I know has
been criticized by their family by their
friends by their teachers we all deal
with criticism okay yeah for different
reasons every single person these people
do not have them Market cornered on
human suffering and that is what they're
trying to do and they're trying to make
us all adapt our entire language and our
entire lives and our and our best
feelings and children's sex education
and everything because they have some
nutty [ __ ] going on in their head no I'm
not pushing my nutty [ __ ] on anybody I
don't want their nutty [ __ ] pushed on
our children yeah oh our suffering our
suffering yeah welcome to the [ __ ]
world we all suffer as a school there
are interesting it's got huge there's a
store where I grew up they never I grew
up in Brighton right about five miles to
Bridgewater grew up there are now 85
kids identifying as gender fluid
non-binary it is nonsense it's confusing
that's proof that it's legit just
programming because that didn't happen
60 70 years ago 10 years it didn't
happen 10 years ago proof that when they
just talk about it non-stop it makes
people transition
no we're finally and making it okay no
you're not you know what the three
Muslims made such a good point on the
podcast today they said what are your
goals and I said to become financially
free you know with so I could be have
money and time freedom and they're like
is that what you really want or is that
because of you grow up in a liberal
capitalist Society where that's
basically the goals of where you live
like if you grew up in a Muslim Society
your goals would be to follow the word
of God and become as good of a person as
you can I was like you're totally right
it's just like about the environment
what you're programmed to like want to
do you know what I mean yeah I mean you
discovered that on your own yeah but
like everyone I wouldn't call you overly
programmed no I it's I'm not like I'm
I'm definitely a lot less I think you're
going a little deeper on that than it
needs to be no but I'm I'm saying like
because you grew up in a society like
this where money is so valued and making
money and all that then it's like yeah
like that's what everyone's goal is it's
like look Health [ __ ] girls [ __ ]
everything I'm just gonna get rich
that's also like such an empty mindset
it's like so empty like just I'm just
gonna get money yeah not everybody
thinks like that and I know but like
that's a big thing it's like people just
like lose their lives over money and
like just destroy their morals over
money and it's like well those same
people those are the same people who who
a different version of that person is
losing their lives and losing their
morals over heroin or over sex it's just
a it's just another addiction it's
confusing everybody
can you say there are a hundred ways to
identify your gender not male and female
there are a hundred waiters you could be
a 108 he's compassionate and you know
I like India
better than you being fired because
actually I intensely keen on this cancer
to learn but what would be better
I don't want to think how you think is
what you mean you want to fire me
because you want me to think what are
you people on Twitter about liberals
today is they've become so illiberal
they're interested in making other
people agree with them and think like
them and if they don't they know
platform them they ban them they cancel
them they sign petitions against people
inspired and it is utter nonsense do you
ever think you go too far Benjamin do
you ever get some of those sometimes
yeah you must recognize them
not on gender and the reason I
identified as a two-spiration guy is so
smug he's so smug the activists this
dude sucks it sucks can we can we do we
have to finish watching this because
she's annoying I completely support all
transgender people who transition I
don't support this hundred gender
nonsense because I think it trivializes
and demeans and makes a mockery of what
people are into you and most people who
have transitioned are on peers side
using that phrase I'm somebody that
challenging this ridiculous notion that
there are now a hundred genders that is
dangerous can I just I think the hundred
gender thing has thrown everybody
surely
some people I totally understand and and
sympathize with people who have an issue
with gender stereotyping but a hundred a
hundred ways to Define what if you've
created this problem of non-binary
people people who don't consider
themselves male or female and these are
the terms we have for them to identify
but hundred well I mean those are the
different terms that people have
actually can you describe different ones
how many can you name well we're not
going to go into that because you don't
need to be a world gender expert you
just need to be compassionate people
your idea of compassion a mine are two
different things yes I've seen I've seen
the compassion shown to me in the last
week it's zero in fact abuse right and
what you actually want you want people
to identify as anything they want right
to the point that someone like me goes
okay in that case I want to be a
two-spirit penguin then you go nuts
because that's not a gender
neither is any of this other [ __ ] you've
made up done we're done yeah thank you
it's one way logic yikes I don't know
thanks for watching save yourselves and
your children from the world NPC culture
get away from it stay out of it be aware
of it and that's it don't go too deep
[Music]
[Music]
don't fall